unless you've been living under a rock
you've probably tried asian skincare
products already skincare culture is a
bit different in asia so there are lots
of awesome asian products that we don't
really get in western countries plus
they're usually budget-friendly today
i'm going to be reviewing some really
awesome asian beauty products i've tried
recently as well as some that were
pretty bad a lot of these are products
that viewers have recommended to me
they're some of those cult asian
products that you've heard a lot about
online yes it is mostly sunscreens there
are five in there but there's also some
cleansing products as well as makeup
this video is sponsored by starvana
which is why i got all of these they
have a massive range of asian beauty
products they've also given us a
discount code to use as well we're
starting with the can make mermaid skin
gel uv this is an spf 50 plus pa 4
pluses sunscreen it was a holy grail
sunscreen of mine but then they
reformulated or repackaged i'm not
entirely sure so it looks like the old
version which i really loved became the
clear version and the whitening one that
one purposely makes your skin a little
bit whiter which is quite popular in
asia this sunscreen is really
beautifully light on the skin it's also
unscented and it's not really siliconey
i have this problem where when i use
sunscreens with a lot of silicones they
often become quite oily throughout the
day on my skin it also doesn't have
alcohol i know alcohol is a problem for
a lot of people it's not really an issue
for me but if that's what you're looking
for this is great it works really well
under makeup and there's zero white cast
on my skin at least it's also fine
around my eyes there's none of that eye
stinging now the filters in this there's
octanoxate juvenile a plus zinc oxide
titanium dioxide and tino sorbets i
reviewed the old version and this is the
same so this is back up to holy grail
status i highly recommend it our next
sunscreen is the neville uv super water
gel 50. this is spf 50 and pa with three
pluses so it's a little bit low in
protection than the can make sunscreen
this is a super lightweight sunscreen
and it has this effect where when you
put it on your skin it feels like it
bursts into water so it feels super
refreshing after you've applied it it is
very lightweight but you can still feel
it a little bit on your skin this is the
80 gram bottle if you buy the slightly
larger version it comes in a convenient
pump the filters are octanoxy dhhb and
octal trizone it does have a pretty
strong alcohol smell when you put it on
at first my main issue with it is the
slightly lower protection but as an
everyday sunscreen it is really nice now
onto two of the more confusing
sunscreens i've tried lately the isn't
tree sunscreens these are both from the
hyaluronic acid range and as you can
tell they look pretty much the same and
that's where the confusion came in that
both spf 50 plus and pa with four pluses
i saw julian scamander14 who does a lot
of sunscreen reviews on instagram he has
really dark skin and he was using one of
these and it looked fantastic on his
skin so i was really excited to try this
of course i grabbed the wrong one which
is the perfect sunblock
the packaging is really not friendly for
those of us who are usually in a rush
and not super observant the perfect
sunblock peeled massively on my skin and
i was actually rushing off to a picnic
with one of my friends who has brown
skin and i was going to give him a
sunscreen and i packed this one of
course and then i noticed it turning
white on my skin so then i had to pull
that out of the bag he didn't turn up to
the picnic anyway so i guess it was fine
i did end up using it on my arms which i
forgot to put sunscreen on before the
picnic so luckily i had this and it is
quite nice on the arms it uses titanium
dioxide which is why it has this
massively whitening effect some people
have asked me if a titanium dioxide only
sunscreen can actually have this pa plus
plus plus claim in other words can it
actually be broad spectrum and give good
uva protection the answer is yes a lot
of older books and papers say that
titanium dioxide can't give good uva
protection but there are newer titanium
dioxide ingredients out there now that
tick off the criteria for broad spectrum
on their own so they give a good spread
of uva and uvb protection titanium
dioxide is a particular mineral
sunscreen ingredient which means it is
in lots of little solid particles with
these solid particulate sunscreen
ingredients there are lots of things
that you can change like the particle
size and the surface treatments that
will change how that ingredient performs
when it goes under uv so in other words
what uv wavelengths it will absorb more
so for example kroda which is a cosmetic
ingredient company they give an example
formulation that uses their own titanium
dioxide ingredients and it ends up with
spf 65 and uva pf26 which would
translate to the same rating as this i
don't know the exact titanium dioxide
ingredient that this sunscreen is using
of course but
that rating is possible with just
titanium dioxide but anyway the white
cast and the pilling disqualified this
for me and overall it was just a very
rude experience but it turns out the one
that i was meant to get was the watery
sun gel and this one is a really nice
sunscreen it uses a whole bunch of
organic sunscreen ingredients so
octophylate homozylate be mt mbbt
polysilicon 15 and dhhb it's pretty nice
and light and hydrating it's not as
ridiculously light as the neville or the
biore but it is really good for oily
skin it could probably stand to be a
little bit more hydrating though
sunscreen number five is the thank you
farmer sun project light sun essence
this is an spf 50 plus but only pa with
three pluses this applies with a similar
sort of silky feeling as the can make
sunscreen but it is a bit heavier it has
a whole bunch of chemical sunscreen
ingredients dhhv octanoxate octazylate
homozylate and octocrylene the fact it's
a bit heavier and the lower uva rating
means that this can't make it into my
holy grails but i think it is quite a
nice everyday sunscreen if you have
maybe drier skin and you want something
a little bit heavier that can double up
as moisturizer now on to the cleansing
products this is the unique calendula
complete cleansing oil this is a
fragrance free cleansing oil which
usually i'm a little bit hesitant about
but
it smells like a cooking oil and i can't
actually smell any rancidity in this
that's that slightly sour smell that you
sometimes smell in oils usually with
cooking oils when you've had them open
for too long i have only had this for a
few months but i also can't find any
reviews that have ever mentioned it so
it's quite possible that it stays
non-rancid for quite a while a lot of
cleansing oils have noticeable rancidity
after a few months and that's because a
lot of oils will oxidize with oxygen and
light if the oils in a cleansing hole
aren't selected carefully especially if
they're using plant oils and especially
if there's no masking fragrance then
this rancidity can be a bit of an issue
and it's much more obvious because this
is the sort of product that you would
put really close to your nose so this is
actually a really nicely done fragrance
free cleansing oil i would still prefer
something that didn't smell so much like
cooking oil but if you can't handle
fragrance and you prefer plantars in
your cleansing oils then this is a
really nice option you can also pick
ones which have more stable oil so you
would avoid any plantars that have lots
of linoleic acid for example maybe stick
to things like mineral oil jojoba oil
and squalane this is pretty good at
getting rid of makeup and it rinses off
pretty cleanly and it comes in my
favorite packaging for cleansing all
which is a pump bottle really convenient
the only thing is i do like a little bit
of a subtle fragrance in my cleansing
products and that's the same problem i
have with the harder labo gokujian
hydrating face wash this is a cleanser
that comes with a foaming top and it is
fragrance free which is a selling point
for a lot of people but it's just not
really up my alley this is a really nice
cleanser it's not very hydrating it's
not very stripping either and it is
pretty much just fine in every way but
it's just a little bit joyless i didn't
realize this would be such an issue for
me but
it just kind of felt like a chore to use
it feels a bit like the skincare version
of soylent nutritionally it's exactly
what you need with nothing extra but
kind of feels a bit flavourless i
definitely prefer it over a product
that's really nice to use but strips my
skin massively but i would just prefer
something a little bit more exciting but
for those of you who just want a really
solid cleanser that works well and has
no frills then this would be a fantastic
pick it just isn't really my cup of tea
now on to the makeup this is the hair
essential spicy nude balm in naked
almond that is a lot of innuendo for a
lipstick this is actually the lipstick i
am currently wearing i guess we don't
really talk about asian makeup a lot
because makeup is something that it's a
lot easier to try in person so this was
a bit of a blind buy but i'm really glad
i got it it is a really pretty brick red
color it looks a lot like my favorite
lipstick which is toast of new york by
revlon but it's a sheerer color and it
looks more like a gloss there is a
little bit of a minty feeling on my lips
not a ton
and the fragrance is really nice it
smells like a cup of tea i also really
prefer this sort of stick format which
is a little bit harder to find with
asian brands most asian brands that i've
looked at have those doe foot gloss like
applicators and while they're okay
they're not my preferred way of applying
lipstick i prefer a much more oily
product i think maybe i'm just not quite
coordinated enough to deal with a doe
foot on a daily basis i also tried some
gel eyeliners from the brand mercy
these gel eyeliners stay on really well
and they didn't transfer at all even
though my eyelids are super oily this
one is a normal sized one and this one
is a slim eyeliner both of these don't
blend that well once you've put them on
your skin you do have to work quite
quickly and so if you're using your
finger just like apply it smudge it
apply the next part smudge it again i am
wearing it on my eyelids at the moment
and you can see i haven't really
bothered blending it much because it is
actually quite difficult the regular
eyeliner comes with a sharpener in the
end that you can pull out
now the slim one is really cool it is
only 1.5 millimeters in diameter which
means it's really thin it's really easy
to control and you can draw a really
good cat eye with it really easily it
does tend to break off really easily
because it is so slim so the mercy
website does give a tip where you only
wind up so there's about a millimeter
sticking up before you start using it
the problem is because it is so skinny
there isn't that much product inside
this like the cylinder total mass is
just tiny it is 0.05 grams which is 50
milligrams versus
in the big one you have 10 times as much
of that solid black product 0.5 grams
and even that isn't very much product
compared to my usual revlon colorstay
cream gel which is 1.2 grams so it's a
bit more than twice as much as in the
big one and it is
24 times as much as in the slim one so
while the slim one is a really cool
product and i haven't really seen
anything like that on the market before
it is something to keep in mind it is
probably not going to be the product
that you use to draw a really thick
eyeliner line on every day so all of
those are from starvanna they've given
me a discount code which is right here
if you've tried any of these products
before let me know what you thought of
them please consider subscribing if
you've learned something new also click
the notification bell so you don't miss
any uploads and i will see you next time
to nerd out more